[Music]
who are you
the story of chiang chi
was actually very personal
i wanted to look at what superhero could
be
what it would mean to me
to be able to add not only one character
shanghi
but to add a whole cornucopia of asian
faces that are representing something
i've never really seen before
what happened to your shirt
i never thought in my wildest dreams
that i would be here
i was pretty much the biggest marvel fan
that you could possibly imagine to be
the first lead asian superhero in the
mcu this is every kid's dream
for many of us who grew up in the west
whose parents immigrated you know we
never really saw ourselves on screen
meaningfully chiang chi will be an
important piece of that conversation i'm
chinese american i was raised here i was
interested in exploring what that story
could be like it's an amazing
opportunity to write a little bit more
of my experience
everyone on this movie they care about
the story whether it's the language the
symbology everything was done with care
with research we all bonded because it's
just such an important film
you were meant for greatness
every time i talk to my parents they
always lead with the same question did
you work with tony leung today and did
you work with michelle yo today tony and
michelle are
as legendary as you can get
you are a product of all who came before
you the good and the bad every marvel
superhero has their own story and
everyone is so different when your
storytelling is good it transcends the
culture because at the end of the day
we're telling a story about love about
family i hope this movie is something
that anybody will feel connected to
it's time to show them who i really am
[Applause]
[Music]